from cnbc
january 6 committee demands a huge trove
of trump white house records
burying the lead here this is the
official reporting from cnbc but what
they're not telling you as much as the
key point is the house committee
investigating january 6 assaulting the
capital formerly demanded records
related to at least 30 members of former
president donald trump's inner circle
what they don't include in this is that
the list includes a ton of other people
we're talking like run-of-the-mill
activists we're talking about look
you've got scott pressler
why is scott pressler
on this list for a demand for records
scott pressler is an activist who
registers republicans to vote and cleans
up garbage
what does he have to do with january 6
you got alex jones owen troyer
i don't even know some of these people
are
do you guys know who tracy diaz is no
disrespect i don't know what that is
that's uh that's uh tracy beans
oh on twitter i don't know yeah i don't
even know i mean was was was tracy even
there i have no idea so all of these
names on this list these are the uh the
official demands they want all of these
names all look at this one they say
they want all documents and
communications within the white house on
january 6 20 21 relating in any way to
the following and they say the january
sex rally the march donald j trump sarah
matthews hope hicks mark meadows dan
scavino pat
sippellone mark short patrick philbin
eric hirschman stephen miller greg jacob
i mean it's it's it's everybody it's
it's trump's admin you you've got uh
kaylee mcinerney then you go down i
think the what's what's the the really
the scariest thing about this is when
they start naming activists from april
1st 2020 through january 20th 2021 all
documents and communications concerning
the 2020 election and relating to the
following individuals
and that's where we see
you know ali alexander brandon strzok
rose tennant vernon jones michael flynn
alex jones owen schroyer scott pressler
jack posobik
angela stanton king george papadopoulos
mark burns roger stone george flynn i
mean
i don't even know enrique tario michael
codry i don't even know who some of
these people are but these are not
politicians katrina pearson
who so who who's that that she was the
spokesman for the trump campaign in 2016
chief spokesman and were these people
there no why do they want communications
going back
here before which and keep in mind about
what it says what it says and and my my
legal team has been over this with a
fine tooth comb what they're requesting
for
if you look at this specific subsection
where it names you know kind of the
activists
it
doesn't even mention the actual january
6 event itself it just says
all documents and communications
concerning the 2020 election
from april to january 20th so
essentially if you had any comment
whatsoever any communication whatsoever
with uh with the government from that
entire it's almost a year that they're
asking for of the private records
personal communications that they are
trying to subpoena this has nothing to
do with january 16th now they'll tell
you very quickly what they're trying to
do with me and i know exactly what
they're trying to do with me is they are
trying to go after my white house
sources they want to know who it is that
i've been in communication with at the
white house that of course
is being done in a way where i'm keeping
them private they're giving me
information it's a network of people
that send stuff to me and then i get it
out right they know that this has been a
thorn in the side of the body
administration because there are some
people that are even in the bible
administration that are looking at this
they want to get into my records and
they want to get that out well i'm here
to say right now to nancy pelosi and
anybody else you're not getting it
you're not getting my sources you can
send whatever you want to me you can do
whatever you want to me i'm not giving
it up because these people are patriots
they are telling me the truth they're
telling me the truth about what's going
on when it comes to covid and the
government's response they're telling me
the truth about what's going on in the
ground in kabul they're telling the
truth about what's actually going on
behind the scenes at the white house as
opposed to the lies that you people are
putting out in your press briefings and
so if you want to come for it you better
be ready this is a absolutely better be
ready and your stand is admirable and
they're going to come after you and i i
and you're a hero for standing up to
them this this is a two-fold in my
opinion a process the first is to punish
those people who were on the wrong side
this is to punish them you specifically
the people on this list this is the the
scary part of using political power is
to punish your enemies but the second
part also is to send a warning for
people in the future don't join the
wrong side because this is what's going
to happen to you this is meant to
silence and scare people who want to get
politically active the only reason why i
didn't go january 6th is because like i
had something on the farm it was a
two-hour drive i think it was cold and
rainy and i kind of actually felt bad i
was like you know what i should be there
there's like 40 000 people
but like i just wait
i can't make it i just i honestly
couldn't make it and it was like ah i
can't but what if you know how many
people
would have made the same decision and
that is to say to people like me
next time there's a rally like this
don't go daniel because you look look
what they'll do to you owen shroyer just
got charged he was released i guess he
can't talk about it but so so the way
this works is
they're they're making a demand for
internal government documentation on
these individuals that's correct jack
right so what it is is this is the first
step in the process what they're doing
now is they're going for internal
government documents that would have
been held under the trump administration
as pertains to the presidential records
act as well as anything else that might
be on file regarding this um you know
the uh regarding the election at least
there's different subsections and
there's different types of things that
they're asking for for different groups
of people and so but by and large it's a
letter to the national archivist so what
that is is all those records so when you
go to a presidential museum and you'll
see that they have the entire records of
that administration there if you go to
you know the kennedy museum or the
roosevelt museum and so what they've
done now obviously trump doesn't have a
museum yet up um obama doesn't even have
his museum up yet he's getting some uh
legal trouble with that but what they do
is the national archivist will set all
of those records aside
so then the question becomes
does and will trump
uh come back and i think they know
what's going to happen is that he'll
exert what's called executive privilege
over either all of these records or a
portion of these records and then of
course that's where the politics comes
in and they're going to demand well hey
these people were outside the
administration like myself i wasn't a
member of the administration i was
working for one american news at the
time um who i actually did have a phone
call with today and and we you know we
talked about everything and we said and
they said you know we got your back jack
now i have a trivia question for you if
you wanted to avoid the presidential
records act
and you set up a separate email server
in what room of your house would you put
that service basement
i would i have a recent the basement
bathroom right the basement bathroom
that's exactly what it is exactly so
this is what that's how you buy it's
actually a great way to set up
explaining this you set up
jackpotworld.com
and you have everyone and i am steve
johnson a busho and we all use this and
it's run out of my basement and that way
when the big power of foia comes in and
says we want to see your records you say
i'm not using any government right
to be fair i'm using
but come on come on
daniel we have to fact check you okay
this is fake news she was just she had
those those emails were yoga that was
yoga yeah
a daughter's wedding i guess she's not
doing the yoga that much
see we all understand exactly exactly
yeah hillary was just talking about yoga
so
ten plus thousand thirty thousand thirty
thousand emails
server to avoid government exactly for
this example for this exactly exactly
for this purpose because when an
activist
uh partisan group gets together and they
decide that they want to expend and come
it's a complete overreach a massive
overreach of political capital and
government capital where they want to go
into people's private lives like this
this is one way that if you are somebody
like hillary clinton who's running these
off the books operations we saw that
what sydney blumenthal was running
around libya right before the invasion
and all of this right that she's able to
do that mixing classified information in
and out but if you're someone you know
and that's totally fine when you're
hillary clinton but if you're someone in
the trump administration right like
imagine if you know donald trump had a
private email another guy doesn't use
email but you know we know what would
happen this is what happens when you're
on the other side of that they will come
after you with the full force of the
federal government and what i've been
told what i've been told from a lot of
people is okay
that's
the presidential records act this is
just step one yeah well well jack this
is not going to end
this have you given any thought to
what job you'll be doing in the gulag
yes um
yes as a matter of fact i have so i have
already picked out my gulag job and you
know it's it's already taken and but
it's actually going to be providing a
service to everyone else you know who's
on the list and probably everyone in
this room who will be there with me um
especially ian yeah well he he'll be the
graphene jack will be playing bass and
so i'll be playing bass yeah no so i'm
going to be providing the mandarin
lessons for everybody so that we'll i'll
be able to teach you up in mandarin
we'll be to learn learn very quickly
we'll you know we'll try to get
characters i know with some daniel you
know you might be in the remedial class
yeah that's fine
that way i'll be working for nike i'll
be making
you'll be very happy right and
and that way we'll be able to
communicate with the guard so it'll
actually be quite useful
that's good planning ahead that's great
yeah how do you say sounds effing
awesome in mandarin
you know we let we joke about this stuff
but uh
this is not this list clearly is not
about january 6th no no it it it's
calling for records but related to the
election what they've what they've what
they want to do what they've been trying
to do which every step of the way has
been
uh they've just literally gutted
and mutilated the american republic
from the first impeachment to the second
impeachment to the constant harassment
to the lies in the media they hated
trump so much that they were willing to
do anything and by the way
it's not done though so we're doing
lists now
do you i'll i'll just say this right now
every step of the way since going back
to 2017 2018 i've been talking about
some kind of civil conflict civil war
i've said i see no reason for this to
de-escalate now i would i have no
problem saying right now for all i know
everything just slows down people
finally say i'm done with the conflict i
don't want to be fighting anymore and
everyone shakes hands and we and we move
along all of a sudden republicans
democrats hugging in the hallways but i
don't see any reason for that to happen
then not only do we have a shootout last
weekend in portland between left and
right wing groups you now have
predominantly democrats let's be real
kinzinger and cheney are not
anything other than democrats with a
republican for a name
they're coming out and saying we want to
know about the election we want to know
about what their strategies were their
campaigns we want to know what the with
the trump administration any of these
people and the government were talking
with these people about scott pressler
the guy who cleaned up garbage in
baltimore and you know here's what's
going to happen here's the first step is
the list right
the next step is they you say they won't
get it they're not going to get they're
not going to get that information right
here's my prediction that could be wrong
but here's just a thought i had maybe
maybe it's a long shot
they'll say okay well how about we have
the archivist start
checking to make sure those records
exist
and then if they're gonna you know and
then the judge will be like well before
they can be released there has to be a
challenge and there's an injunction
then they leak
and then private communications start
leaking out of context all of a sudden
news stories emerge accusing people of
very serious wrongdoing and it's used to
seed
very very bad press
and and shock content through the
midterms and into the next presidential
election and how they'll do this also
and this is just how the justice
department works when it's pursuing a
lead is
they will say all right well this is
only official government correspondence
so any dot gov whitehouse.gov email
address that mentions jack by name and
then they'll read the email and they'll
say jack was at the christmas party on
thursday and they'll say well we need to
know more about the christmas party and
who else was at the christmas party
lydia was at that christmas party well
now we need olivia's records because
lydia is now tied to jack because and it
will just get bigger and bigger and
bigger and then all of a sudden now
you're turning over things that aren't
whitehouse.gov now you are turning over
private stuff and it's like look you
know we went to the d.a and there's
enough evidence here that yeah we have
to keep digging but you keep you keep
digging and eventually ever all of us
are guilty of some what's that book
crime of day we're all guilty of like
four crimes a day they'll dig they'll go
to a grand jury a non-adversarial court
they'll say look at this
these people are implicated in january 6
for this reason and the grand jury's
going to be like do it indictment right
and they're going to go and then they'll
go to
uh even prior to that but they'll go to
what comcast verizon etc and they're
going to say hey we're you know we're
investigating this it's very important
we need these records we need to go
through all this so you know turn it all
over and of course they will like i'm
under no
uh
i want to know aspersion that they what
they want to do what they're trying to
do here is remember george papadopoulos
the fact that he's on this list as well
he was caught up in this he he got a
date wrong right he got a date wrong in
the first one of these witch hunts
during russiagate so he got the date
wrong in russiagate and so he went to
jail for a week because when he sat down
and had that conversation he couldn't
remember when he met the guy who talked
about hillary's emails you know i said
it was this day was actually a month
before you know
um you know a year later right that's
how they get you that's what they're
looking for is perjury
that's why trump refused to go in person
and said he'd have his draft a letter
written only right so my lawyers are
preparing a number of methods to to
prevent any of this but if they if they
do try to subpoena me and ask me to go
for any of my sources um that's that's
the hard line i will not give you
anything in regards to that in fact i'm
not going to comply with any of these
requests if i have any choice in the
matter whatsoever i'm not going to
comply i'm not going to have anything to
do with this i'm not going to listen to
what you say look
i spent a year at guantanamo bay already
send me back i don't care send me to
gitmo i've been there already
you weren't there as a prisoner yeah you
have to phrase that properly i don't
care
not much difference
honestly not much difference between
i've been on one side of the glass i'll
be on the other side of glass i don't
care
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you